on this episode lewis stopped by to talk
greatness
[Music]
this is
ask Gary B
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 157 of the askgaryvee
show
aka if you got a book come on and Hawk
that [ __ ] on the show first my
father-in-law now my good buddy Lewis
Lewis for the very few in the
vaynernation that don't cross over and
know who you already are why don't you
give a little bit of your spiel and then
India and whatever we'll get into the
show okay a little bit about me
yes about me uh I met this guy how many
years ago did I meet you maybe seven
years ago was it during the crush' tour
2009 2009 uh this guy inspired me to
build a business and take it to a whole
nother level I was in the transition I
was sleeping on my sister's couch I had
a cast on it broke my wrist playing
professional football and the amount of
hustle that this guy had really inspired
me to figure out what I want to do next
with my life so I spent a lot of time
researching finding mentors studying
taking a lot of action making a ton of
mistakes but learning along the way in
the process of taking an action and
built a couple seven for your businesses
along the way and then started a podcast
and that's where the book is coming from
the podcast seems to be the place where
your brand took a different level right
like for me from afar you know you were
playing in a space of a lot of people
trying to build personal brands and
things that nature and how does one
differentiate when didn't you get
serious about the podcast why did you
get serious about the podcast system
because you mentioned something me in
the car in st. Louis Missouri when I
drove you from an event to another event
or something in a hotel and you said I
see you making a lot of money and
building an audience but you're not at
the mainstream level yet you said
something like you're not the mainstream
media level yet and that's where I want
to see you go so you said this to me and
I remember taking it to heart because I
was making a lot of money I was growing
I was like two people in the press want
to have me on their show yep and I said
I got a bill you've made the mainstream
exactly and so I spent a lot of time
really figuring out what does that mean
to build a brand what does it mean to
like create different type of content
the podcasting world in 2012 late 2012
when I was seeing other friends getting
into it I realize like this is something
that I could this is happening this is
happening and I was like I think I could
do this
ya know these guys can do it I could do
it yep I didn't know what to expect I
just said for the first year I'm not
gonna try to make any money yep not
going to take any sponsors I'm just
gonna go and interview people put out
content the best people I can find and
give them my all and so it's interesting
in March I come out with the askgaryvee
book that's the play of your podcast
into the book what are you promising
people that have listened to your
podcast in this book that doesn't
translate from the yeah here's the thing
you know interview always inspiring
people you know you've been on the show
and it's like we get these great lessons
we hear these stories and that's great
but what are the actionable exercises
and practices that we can use in our
daily life to take that action and get
the results it's one thing to be
inspired did you write this did you do
it the way I do were you have a
ghostwriter and you audio it like Apple
people that helped me yeah that's a lot
of interviewing back and forth a lot of
editing back and forth yep can you write
a little bit yeah I mean I'll exit guy
it's kind of challenging yeah um you
know it's a hard work I can't write
write Rodya and Steve that means why you
know one of the principles have you ever
got an email from hey who one of the
princess is building a championship team
yep and I know that in order to put out
a great product and yet have a great
team around me of writers editors
publisher to support the process cuz I
couldn't do it on my own very cool in a
way good for you Congrats nice howdy
wins it out it's out today all right
well let's link that up yes the big day
I'm humbled that you want to be on this
show on your bigoted what else are you
doing today media wise I did Fox and
Friends this morning are ya good day New
York this morning Fox five and doing Fox
and Friends this weekend but this is the
most important show the whole week
on that note India let's get into this
show I like when we get that thing what
is that called again what's that um
harmony
it's a harmony we're harmonizing all
right let's go India Martina asks when
making important decisions do you trust
your own gut and experience or do you
count on some advisor as well who's your
go-to person on a real decision do you
have one
you know it used to be my dad yep but he
had a pretty extreme car accident about
10 years ago so I'm sorry really
comprehend certain things at that level
anymore but our go-to guy named Stewart
Jenkins okay works at a big brand called
Decker's a billion-dollar shoe company
that owns UGG and Tetons I know in all
those brands and he's just like a
straight shooter tells me how it is
great Family Guy doesn't try to pot
doesn't try to pander to what you want
to here you go like you just like tells
me he's got such good integrity or
morals why I don't speak to anybody I
don't want anybody touching idea exactly
yeah
so I talk to him with really issues how
much what percentage of decisions do you
make on your gut a lot what percentage
high II honor is that okay so you're
just you really don't give a [ __ ] what
Stewart says no I advised with everyone
yes tough decisions but I always know
the answer God I mean it's yeah I know
the answer but I feel like it has
anybody wavered you from the answer
people give me different opinions but I
always know yes they have they have they
waiver me okay and then I realize I
shouldn't have taken that advice so at
times where you haven't gone with your
gut and you've gone with people that you
think have made it or other things it
hasn't paid off so you're now defaulting
as you're maturing into your own place
yes I mean for me I've always been that
way and I think that what happens in
teresting to hear your perspective it's
fun to have guests a little bit cuz you
would have gotten my answer of you know
no and like I respect my mom and dad and
things of that nature but I don't even I
love them with all my heart I just make
my own decisions I just don't I don't
know what else to say about this but
it's interesting I got from the
athlete's background so I was constantly
coached consciously shorty back yep so I
like to have the coach that makes sense
in an environment so I can just take
action and apply the information but a
lot of the times I know the answer it's
just trusting myself that makes a lot of
sense yeah I I think the the one thing
is actual item from this show taking a
theme from your book and will continue
to act on it - uh I think should really
try if you're watching the show to try
the opposite on the next decent side
decision as long as it's not a top-three
decision your life then do you if it's a
fourth biggest decision type of thing
try the other way as context I may even
try to I know I can't but
I said that last didn't even last a
sentence but I think now be interesting
because I'm intrigued by you ending up
in this place my intuition is a lot of
people end up in that place as they get
older and older because at some level
you'd rather up for my for me I'd rather
go down my way you know that to me is
probably the thing when you're making
real decisions there's up side then
there's down side that's why they're big
decisions if I'm going to go down I want
to go down because I screwed up like not
because somebody else gave me advice and
it just didn't work out that's just yeah
all right I do a lot of segwaying going
on
Gabriel asks what is the best example in
your life where your ego has gotten the
best of you how significant was it in
retrospect well this is great right
because you've already dropped ego I
almost called this the ego show so you
know uh what was the question
well then ego got the best of you yeah
oh my gosh should I go sure yeah
for me oh man any relationship that I've
been in I allow my ego to get the best
of me in the past
yeah where it's not like girls you mean
yes okay go ahead and then it just
affects me it like consumed what's the
ego part like you think you're hotter
than them no no it's like oh after like
after like I don't know it's like after
we break up or end things it's okay you
don't want to call first and say it's
that way school run I don't know it's
just like I'm still holding on to things
and I can't let the certain things go
and I'm like mad still or pissed or
white didn't work out and that holding
onto things deposed a fully letting go
yeah will hold me back in other areas of
my life and just yeah my health my
business like making clear decisions and
that ego I got a fully let go miss
interesting what about you
for me I think you know with ego I think
it's things that I don't know so I
thought you know everything well I know
everything that actually has happened so
so maybe my ego of recognizing well know
India like let me give you an example I
know you're laughing over there now
the time let me explain I would tell you
that I / it was the right business
decision but ego of like not doing a lot
of television shows because I feel like
the world's gonna change and I want to
own the IP maybe kept me away from being
fifty thousand times bigger because
clearly I'd be uncredible I'd probably
be the biggest TV star on TV by hisashi
doing because I still believe in this
thesis which is I can't you both but you
can we can't what are you waiting for
you don't busy you [ __ ] here I know
anything's going on like / well nice
beginning oh you're on one of the three
floors of four offices like there's a
lot going on um so I'm wondering if he
goes kept me away from mainstream media
um you're just on Bloomberg this morning
right yeah that's different than hosting
a show uh it'd be the biggest TV person
I believe that Louis say it again Lynne
usually the biggest TV personality yeah
why you the saying cuz I know you don't
want to say haha what you say no see
what she did she had that was good uh
cut that clip for me uh d-roc just a
ringtone so I uh I think there's been an
enormous amount of things that have
impacted me predicated my ego I just
don't know what they are because they're
the things that I didn't do versus the
things that I did the things that I've
done with my ego I know the outcomes
they've all been pretty damn positive
it's the things that I don't that I'm
passing on that I can never play out and
know what would have happened that's
where my upside is on the table my me
being bigger financially brand happiness
opportunity me being bigger predicated
on my nose not my yeses what would be
the ultimate show that you could have on
any network any time who would you be
doing with would it be yours yeah what
topic you know it's funny I don't I
don't I've thought about that a lot and
I don't think about a lot meaning
meaning I used to think about the format
what would I want to do I'm so not in
the mindset of having a TV show right
now I'm so enjoying this I'm enjoying
the way I'm going about marketing this
and the white spaces and where the
world's going and how over-the-top is
changing the world I mean look if I had
a business show on Netflix if Netflix
came to me right now and said we want to
make you our business show that me
really tough to say no to so I would say
that because it's of the moment um
really it's not mainstream cable or
network no because I'd rather go to
where the pucks going and I'd rather I'd
rather be part of the narrative of you
know those shows house of cards orange
into black then whatever sports deal
they do and then that business show
that's where they competed with CNBC
like you know that's why I did the
podcast I saw yeah that's exactly right
and that's where the upside is you wait
and you let the puck come to you I would
say I would say CNBC and Bloomberg are
interesting to me because it's just
right down the pipe of business like um
but yeah I just I can't get there yeah
yeah let's stand up at your baby I'm
like really all black are you you're all
black great yeah well I'm I'm blackest
black socks look at this black underwear
Wow yeah I'm all black today this really
dark super dark yeah get in there
alright b-b-b asks how do you deal with
losing a client just lost one and I'm
mad as hell yeah mad it sounds good you
know I think mad as hell is appropriate
hyah when I lose a client the first
thing that I think about is what did I
do wrong and then most of time I have an
answer if I don't have an answer I try
to figure it out but I'm pretty
interesting when it comes to losing a
client I'm uh I'm very much on to the
next one
like like that like I on the other hand
I'm very lucky listening to you was
really interesting I was sitting here
and saying my god my ability to like
dump and move on in any situation
relationships business it's the game for
me it's why I'm always in a good mood
like I literally sit on bad news and bad
stuff for fractions of seconds d-roc
shaking his head right in without with
ease and interpersonal relationships
with friends or family love you just say
screw your mouth the next person I
haven't really lost anybody who I would
call in my most inner circle I've had
relationships that have like my longest
girl friend relationships that ended
were predicated on me sitting on it
longer than I was in my head for a long
time anyway so yeah I mean I don't know
like I I'm I've been very blessed that
somebody that meant the world to me
hasn't decided to leave me so that's one
part of it and the other part is I
haven't you know outside of a couple
long-term girlfriend relationship that I
haven't haven't I haven't parted from
anything that's been in my inner core in
business I've had a fire people I care a
lot about but I've come to a place where
I recognized that I was doing more harm
by keeping them here and giving them no
growth here my library so yeah that's
that anything you want to add on that
alright let's do it
Oh Jarek haven't seen Jared she loves
Hamilton he's been popping up a bunch
lately on my feet hey what's going on
Gary be my company got accepted to be a
part of the Alpha program at collision
2016 in New Orleans I've never been to
an event like this so I'm not really
sure what's prepared more how to prepare
for it I was wondering what would you do
if you were in my shoes if you were
going to not necessarily look for money
but more looking to make contacts I'd
appreciate any information any insights
you might have on the situation thanks
right Jarek really legit American flag
waving so beautifully in the background
I did notice the Giants t-shirt so I'm a
little bit pissed with Jarek now Louis
any thoughts on that I mean I think you
know you want to establish your name in
the marketing and business world I
assume you started going to a lot of
events for the first time through the
last half decade how did you approach it
you know I remember when I was broke I
took a greyhound to one of my first
events in 2008 it was in New York it was
like a sports film festival in Philly
I took the Greyhound and I had a suit
jacket and I'm in a carry-on case I
remember I had a hostel room that I got
for like 17 bucks yep because I knew the
value I met a guy named Ben sterner I
think you know who works out of here
he was like you got to come this event
going to meet a lot of powerful people
that's going to help your business your
your relationships your brand so I was
like I got to get there I rented a
hostel for 17 bucks the first night I
walk in late at night and there's
throw-up all over the ground
let's throw up all of the tour all over
the bathroom
20 snoring European guys in the room hit
but I knew the value right when I got to
this event how important was it connect
with influencers and powerful
individuals yes and I stayed up all
night with people and just built a
relationship it wasn't about being at
the event was freaking out where people
are going after that and getting in with
their friends and then creating
friendships with people I never talked
about business or asked for advice
yep I just said what's going on in your
life yeah like how can we be buddy-buddy
and let's do thumb-wrestling wars yeah I
never like idea with yet 2009 or
something it's like let's have a fun and
supposed to talk about the thing you
don't want to talk about right now you
know to me Jarek I think it's a really
good question and I think that I think
that's right right I mean I think some
level if you're not meeting people
you're not hitting on your KPI I think
Luis speaks to patients in a
relationship I think it really matters
you know trying to throw around your
business card or pitch your business is
completely the opposite move I mean just
just place you off the play set an
example
I mean I've been essentially jabbing for
six years with you that's right I've
never asked for anything
I bought a shitload of these books I but
I've never asked for anything except for
this blurb on the back yep which you
know it's a big deal because I don't
like kissing a man oh and also he's can
I come on the show
yeah and I'm gonna show some books yes
which is my own advice right I let's
talk about that a lot which is like cash
in all those chips when you've got your
signature moment like you need this to
do well it's a it's another watershed
moment your career before what's the
guy's name again Jarek Jarek for Jarek I
would not ask anyone for support or help
right now I would just say how can I
give to that person listening judge
listening to Louis's narrative Jarek I
think one of the biggest things that
people make mistakes for is they go for
short term nickels and dimes and set a
long term dollars right so if you're if
you find the the more important the
person you encounter in New Orleans the
more you should not ask for anything too
many times I mean the amount of people
that roll up on me I have no idea who
they are and they want $100,000 for me
because they're going to help me buy the
Jets is a is pretty intense like there's
no context it's it's not the right move
now again back to his story go sleep
with 20 snoring throw up dudes for 17
if you've got a practical financial
problem have the humility to go sleep on
your sister's couch if you have a
financial problem if your financial
problem needs to be solved by you going
to the most important people on first
impact and asking for $25,000
you've put yourself in a bad position so
I think what you need to do is put
yourself in a position where you put no
pressure on yourself to close at this
event but build at this event look at
the long-term think of relationships for
five years down 100% India am I freaking
you up privacy we should pawsley like
when Adam asks will privacy related
issues be the ultimate Achilles heel for
social networks including Facebook I'll
jump in here the answer is no because
there's a pendulum swing the reason
snapchat grew was because it was a safer
place a place that stuff would disappear
I actually think the next wave is gonna
be I think they'll be more closed over
the next decade you got cyber dust cubes
thing like you've got snapchat I think
there's more room for that I think it'll
be another one or two I think the reason
whatsapp and other things that made sure
messaging apps are doing well is in
theory two people it's closed by
comparison but I think actually in the
long long term 1012 you know 8 10 12
years from now there'll be another push
back to open its generational right it's
like fashion right like it's it's like
it goes through absent flaws I guys are
in fact with everybody being so kind of
hipster and the way everybody is now the
other day I was thinking was like crap I
wonder where we're gonna like when are
we gonna go conservative again like when
everybody got the friends haircut and
like like I'm curious like then I was
thing about like grunge which was crazy
weird anyway it made me think about that
and that's how I think about social
networks like this is the mood of a
generation the 60s are different into
70s and 80s and 90s and 2000's
I definitely think people will freak out
about privacy I think Ashley Madison is
a proxy to other things like just
imagine now all of us if all of our
information of every text email and
engagement and I mean texts and
whatsapp's and whatever else you're
using a creep
tinder imagine all those conversations
pop out and it just searchable like
literally Louis everything you've said
digital
yeah and so I I actually think that
happens and then I think Nirvana happens
cuz everybody realizes how flawed
everybody is so like I've got a very
weak positive point of view and where
this all goes I think there'll be some I
do think privacy will contain people to
some different behaviors but I actually
think if you play the chess moves out
everybody's laundry gets aired out which
changes society forever and we roll in a
completely different way and the things
we accept as norms the way we think
about interpersonal relationships and
what makes a good person and a bad
person fundamentally changes with the
great data breach of 2022 because
everyone we realize everyone's a freak
well I'm yet I take it what you want
Louis but I definitely think I
definitely think that that's a real
possibility I I think that I think you
have to happen but I you know I don't
know but I can predict us I I don't like
to predict things that I don't like I
like to predict things that already
happened and everybody didn't realize
they happened this way I'm right I think
that uh I just think it's a real
possibility and I definitely live my
life with all my flaws and what-have-you
with the knowledge of that could happen
and I have to be we have to be prepared
for the repercussions of like I was
saying the right thing is always the
right thing like you know the the N
scores the N score like if you do wrong
things by today's standards and they
become aware like you'll have to deal
with that so you like that you put
yourself out there in such an authentic
way and vulnerable way a lot of times
where you talk about your flaws because
then yes about yes like yes doesn't
matter yes but I'm a human being like
like I think a lot about what I'm doing
things in a very private setting
how would that map's to my public
persona commit like if this hits the fan
like does that undermine what I'm saying
and I try to stay in that Lane because
it'll still at least make sense in my
narrative like you can't be the person
that like like says like that
holier-than-thou guy that was like
cheating on his wife like that was pot
like he can't be that / you can't be
like the prosecutor and go after
prostitution when you're using
prostitutes right like America will not
accept that complete like insanity the
world will accept if you waver I think
we all know we have skeletons I mean I
don't you want to know what Steve's up
to like eggs
you're welcome no worries but like you
know I think I think that we I think I'm
excited and I hope they've lived through
seeing it and I may not and it might be
much longer but I do want us I'm very I
wish people lived the life that I live
which is of course I judge people the
boy do I Anjali like humans are flawed
like in so many ways and we need to
start accepting our shortcomings a lot
more and I wonder if this data thing
which sounds scary
privacy's going to go away it's very
it's Armageddon but I actually think
it's the starting point to to a better
society I like it yeah interesting right
that's it all right Luce want to do any
parting shots we're gonna link up the
book on YouTube and Facebook for you
yeah so another book appreciate it as
mine is my right hook yeah any anything
else on your mind how much longer you do
the along you can do the podcast you
know it's been almost three years
245 episodes today and I don't see
myself slowing down anytime soon knows
keeps getting bigger and bigger than
impact who was today's guest but there
was just myself it's great it sweet so
tell every day I'm doing it who's the
last guest ah the last guest don't blink
right now Cameron recently
who've you had on recently that I had uh
what happens is the reason you don't
know is cuz you is you can them and then
lay them and then roll them out yeah I
have Phil Rosenthal actually but like I
smelled it yes Phil Freddie I did good
dude huh so hey he's interesting right
larious created Everybody Loves Raymond
it's amazing yeah so he was great here
I'll finish with a quote ok yours dear
do you think so is it gonna be we find
out that everyone's a freak no no okay
oh that's kind of like a bomb it
embodies what you know you taught me
what I've learned my whole life the
reason that I feel like I've been able
to get to where I'm at and I think where
everyone can get to where they're at is
a quote I figure who said this but when
I heard it when I was younger kid it
really meant a lot to me it made me feel
like I had a chance and that's nobody
cares how much you know until they know
how much you care hmm I like that my
favorite quote is Jay ETS Jets Jets Jets
is that appropriate I like it
thank you bye thanks good luck
you keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
[Music]